China es ya todo un coloso. Este país es
la mayor potencia comercial del mundo.
Lidera el mercado mundial de cientos de productos
y cuenta con las mayores reservas de divisas
de todo el planeta. Ni siquiera las petromonarquias
del Golfo Pérsico pueden competir con este
gigante.
Así, no es extraño que muchos analistas afirmen
que muy pronto China superará a los mismísimos
Estados Unidos como primera potencia económica…
claro que con muchos más habitantes.
Sin embargo, nos solemos olvidar de un factor
importantísimo: que el PIB no lo es todo
y que el poder económico, el poder de verdad,
tiene una relación muy estrecha con el poder
empresarial, y en ese aspecto, la verdad amigos,
China aún está lejísimos de Estados Unidos.
Y es que, fijaos, entre las 100 mayores empresas del
mundo hay 56 estadounidenses y tan solo 11
chinas.
Y, ojo, esto no es ninguna tontería, las
multinacionales controlan casi el 80% de las
exportaciones mundiales y de la Inversión
Extranjera.
Pero, ahora bien ¿Cuál es la verdadera situación
de las empresas chinas? ¿Cómo están cambiando
las cosas? O ¿Qué podemos esperar? Estas son algunas de las preguntas
que vamos a tratar de responder
en este vídeo. Vayamos a verlo.
Por cierto, este vídeo es un tanto especial
pero… de esto hablaremos más tarde.
De momento, os hago una pregunta ¿Conocéis
esta ciudad?
La economía china ha tenido un crecimiento
impresionante en las últimas tres décadas.
La clave la ha tenido el siguiente concepto:
La fábrica del mundo.
Así es como se conoce a China, un país que
ha conseguido convertirse en toda una potencia
y sacar a cientos de millones de personas
de la pobreza gracias a una premisa: fabricar de todo a
bajo coste.
Juguetes, electrónica, herramientas, ropa…
cuando entramos en una tienda podemos encontrar
cientos de productos diferentes con un denominador
común: todos están fabricados en esas impresionantes
zonas industriales que están repartidas a
lo largo y ancho de toda China.
Sin embargo, para que este país pueda reclamar
de verdad el puesto de primera potencia económica
del mundo, sus empresas tendrán que empezar
a producir cosas mucho más complejas, tendrán
que dejar de competir en coste y embarcarse
en la búsqueda del valor añadido, la producción
avanzada de cosas como bienes de capital,
aviones, equipos médicos o procesadores.
Y de momento ya os adelanto que hoy todos estos
sectores están dominados por las grandes
multinacionales con sede en Estados Unidos,
Corea del Sur, Europa y Japón.
Es verdad, muchos productos de vanguardia
se producen en China, por ejemplo, los Iphone,
pero… tiene truco, porque la aportación
china se limita prácticamente al ensamblado.
Es decir, las empresas compran o producen
en otros países las piezas más complejas
y luego las montan en China.
Para que os hagáis una idea, cada año China
importa más de 200.000 millones de dólares
en semiconductores, que son una parte esencial
en la fabricación por ejemplo de equipos
móviles. Esto es mucho más de lo que
gasta el país en petróleo.
Eso sí, en los últimos años las empresas
chinas han hecho muchísimos avances. Hoy,
una cuarta parte de todas las exportaciones
corresponde ya a bienes de capital, como máquinas,
por ejemplo, o a productos de alta tecnología.
Hay sectores como los de equipos de telecomunicaciones,
turbinas eólicas y trenes de alta velocidad
donde las empresas chinas son líderes mundiales.
Y no solo eso...
Las empresas chinas están
aprendiendo a dar el salto a los mercados
internacionales.
En 2016 se cumplió el 50 aniversario de la
revolución cultural, una terrorífica campaña
con la que Mao quiso purificar la revolución
y terminar con las facciones más aperturistas
y procapitalistas tanto del Partido Comunista
como de la propia sociedad china.
Pues bien, desde entonces las cosas han cambiado
mucho… tanto que hoy China es el segundo
país del mundo con más multinacionales,
solo por detrás de Estados Unidos.
Precisamente, en este vídeo que hicimos sobre
la Eurocopa, os contamos que cada vez se notaba
más la presencia de patrocinadores chinos,
prueba de que las empresas de este país estaban
empezando a dar el salto a los mercados globales…
pues vaya salto.
En 2016, las empresas chinas, se gastaron
la increíble cifra de 225.000 millones de
dólares en comprar empresas extranjeras.
Sólo en Europa y en Estados Unidos se registraron
más de 450 operaciones de compra.
Tal cual como os cuento, los chinos, amigos
de VisualPolitik, han comprado, por ejemplo,
el Inter de Milan, y solo es un ejemplo…
Eso sí, si por algo tienen especial predilección
los empresarios del gigante chino es por invertir
en países emergentes.
Aunque Australia y Estados Unidos son los
dos principales destinos de la inversión
china, más de la mitad de toda la inversión
extranjera directa de este país se realiza en
países en desarrollo, en países de Asia, África, Latinoamérica y el Medio Oriente.
Cuanto más riesgoso es el
país, más dispuestos parecen los chinos
a invertir ahí su dinero.
Pero es que, además, las empresas chinas
están también empezando a competir duro.
¿Quereis una prueba? Pues atentos: si en
2006 sólo había una empresa china entre
las 100 marcas más prestigiosas del mundo, en
2015 ya eran 14.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en algo que conocemos todos de cerca:
la industria de los smartphones.
Hasta hace poco tiempo tener un teléfono
móvil de marca china era como…. ¿Un poco
cutre, verdad?
Pues hoy los cuatro principales fabricantes
chinos, Oppo, Huawei, Vivo y Xiaomi, no es
que se hayan dado a conocer, es que obtienen
más del 10% de todos los beneficios de la
industria a nivel mundial, y su peso crece,
y crece.
¿Otro ejemplo? Lenovo, una multinacional
china que hace unos años compró la división
de portátiles de la mismísima IBM.
Hoy ya es  la mayor empresa
de ordenadores del mundo, y abastece de equipos
incluso al propio Pentágono.
Pero... no le digáis nada a Trump.
¿Queréis aún más ejemplos? Pues los hay
de todos los colores:
Haier, el mayor fabricante de electrodomésticos
del mundo o Cofco, una empresa que está
comprando montones de tierras por todo el
mundo, ya sean campos de caña de azúcar
en Australia, viñedos franceses o plantaciones
de soja en Brasil.
También está, Geely, una empresa de coches
que dará mucho de qué hablar en los próximos
años y que en 2010 compró Volvo.
Sí, Volvo, esa mítica marca de coches suecos,
es de propiedad china.
¡Cómo cambian las cosas!
Pero, si hay un sector, donde China está
tomando de verdad la delantera es, sorprendentemente,
en Internet. Y digo sorprendentemente porque
como seguro sabéis, la red en China está
hipercontrolada y censurada por el gobierno
chino con lo que se llama:
El gran cortafuegos, que bloquea por ejemplo
el acceso a Facebook, Google o The Economist,
por poner solo tres ejemplos.
Pues bien, en China lo normal es hacer casi todo
a través de aplicaciones.
Por ejemplo, cuando vas a China es muy raro pagar con tarjetas, pero muy habitual pagar
con el móvil a través de la megaaplicación
wechat, una super-aplicación que es como
una especie de todo en uno: Facebook, Paypal,
Gmail, Twitter...
Por cierto, Wechat pertenece a Tencent, una
de las quince empresas más valiosas de todo
el mundo, que también es el mayor proveedor
mundial de juegos online y uno de los mayores
accionistas de Tesla… sí, los chinos empiezan
a estar en todas partes.
¿Queréis otro ejemplo de éxito? Sin duda Alibaba,
una empresa de comercio electrónica que factura
cada año más de 450.000 millones de dólares,
mucho más que Amazon e Ebay juntas. No está
mal ¿Verdad? Solo en China tiene 400 millones
de clientes.
Como dijo Napoleón:
“El día que China despierte el mundo temblará”
Pero, tranquilos, antes de echarnos las manos a la cabeza, pensad en todo lo que esto puede suponer:
más competencia, mejores precios, mejores
productos, un desarrollo tecnológico más
rápido…
Vamos, que los consumidores podemos sacar
de este proceso muchos beneficios.
Claro que todo esto también puede tener sus
riesgos… o al menos eso de lo que nos alertan
las agencias de Inteligencia de Estados Unidos:
“La inteligencia de Estados Unidos advierte
que las empresas chinas no son de confianza
y pide al Gobierno Federal bloquear la compra
de empresas estadounidenses en sectores estratégicas
por parte de corporaciones chinas”.
Y luego, por otro lado  también está el riego para muchas de nuestras empresas, que van a tener aún
mucha más competencia… aunque también
oportunidades, como ya os conté en este vídeo.
Eso sí, como se dice, no vendamos la piel
del oso antes de cazarla. Las empresas chinas
aún están muy por detrás tecnológicamente
y, además, están super endeudadas.
Tampoco olvidemos que China es una
dictadura, y eso conlleva que el gobierno
tiene un excesivo peso en las decisiones empresariales.
Y el gobierno, es como todo órgano político,
arbitrario e impredecible.
Si hace unos años, por ejemplo, animaba a las compañías chinas a saltar al exterior y las prestaba
todo el dinero que hiciese falta, ahora han
decidido que quieren lo contrario.
El caso es que hoy si una compañía china quiere comprar una extranjera,
necesita la aprobación expresa del Partido Comunista de China.
Y a eso hay que sumar la censura, la inseguridad
jurídica, las trabas al comercio, la mala
marca de productos chinos, etc, etc, etc.
Vamos, que podemos decir, que hoy por hoy,
salvo grandes errores propios, el liderazgo
económico de Estados Unidos no está en peligro,
al menos en el corto plazo.
Pero bien, como os dije al principio este
vídeo especial para nosotros ¿Por qué?
Enrique os lo cuenta:
Os dijimos que teníamos una sorpresa.
Pues bien, os cuento: Un buen
día nos llamó nuestro amigo Ignacio, de
la Plataforma de autónomos y pequeños comerciantes
de Ávila, y nos dijo: VisualPolitik tiene que venir por Ávila..
Así que, dicho y hecho.
Al fin y al cabo qué mejor plan para una
escapada:
Celtas, romanos, visigodos, árabe y castellanos, todos han pasada por esta
ciudad, patrimonio de la humanidad, a la que,
ojo, algunos han llegado a calificar como
la Jerusalén de Castilla.
Fijaros que impresionante.
Cómo veis, amigos, si os queréis sentir como se sentían Doc y su fiel amigo Marty McFly, viajando en el tiempo,
Ávila es una gran opción. Con sus leyendas
y palacios, con sus condes, sus reyes medievales
y sus reinas moras, os garantizo que aquí os vais a sentir como auténticos caballeros medievales
Pues bien, desde esta fantástica ciudad qué
es Ávila nos despedimos. Si te ha gustado
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.